doch kann man nicht mit ich habe ja man
muss ich habe diamant ich habe alter ich
habe nochmal mein gott oh mein gott
es sind moment ich sage ich sag's dir
gleich ich habe du das heulen
ich habe neun diamanten gefunden kann ja
doch eine vergangenheit als olympia
forza das war eine disziplin die ist
danach wurde die rausgehalten
er hat sich alter willigt erde erzeugt
drauf also wenn ihr den privat trifft
oder werde euch direkt zum damit
entgegen das aber hallo ich meine lieben
freunde herzlich willkommen zu unserer
weiteren folge minecraft war zusammen
mit kinos im wahlkreis scharf da obwohl
du ich reden kann von diesen vier ja nur
du kannst reden die anderen können das
nicht
du hast die schönste verbindung bei mir
auf diesem service einfach einen balken
von diesen zehn recht das ist gut
das freut mich total aber bei mir in
meiner verbindung geht's gut ich
verstehe ich auch klar und deutlich ich
verstehe ich auch perfekt also läuft
eigentlich alles ich habe also bei mir
bei mir habe ich voll so ich habe mein
schwert ich habe meinen helm ich habe
eine spitzhacke und das eisen das ist
jetzt noch das abfackeln ist für dich
mal bitte kurz und abfackeln habe ich
hab' ich hab keine kohle du ja ja ja ich
bin manchmal ein paar
okay okay ich mache ist ein bisschen
hier so so hausmädchens teil so kam ich
nach dem konto
dass ich dann bitte schön
die fackeln sie steckt sie dir irgendwie
hotel mama ich hoffe mal der baum wächst
dass ich bin mir jetzt schon irgendwie
ziemlich sicher dass sie funktioniert
was du da machst aber okay ja ich immer
wieder runter ich glaube ich auch mal
runter gehen einander ja genau also wenn
du wenn du hier wenn du mir nach läuft
dann kommst du auf ebene 3 10 und 13 ist
das wo sich die meisten edelsteine eisen
spitzhacke ja habe ich aber halt nur
eine gut gegangen
haben sie angst vor uns die die 22
rabauken
ich gehe jetzt in eine andere richtung
etwas das hier denn ist ob das denn
jetzt wirklich tot ist oder den smaragd
irgendeine fliege fliegt von meinem
gesicht trotz hierarchie und smaragd und
ich hab ich schon soweit dritter 53
das ist doch mal so traurigkeit aus
wieso ist aber ja wie hoch wir uns
einfach erweisen
aber wie hoch wir uns einfach so
eingebuddelt habe quasi seit wir
angefangen haben das war ein bisschen
blöd so vom zerfall zu geben dass tätig
war
da haben sich bestimmt auch schon wieder
ganz ganz viele zuschauer die faust in
den arsch geschoben und gelacht wenn du
dir und masturbiert schön aber es läuft
es läuft läuft et les ich hab auch schon
wieder reisen und dann kriegen wir
zumindest mal glaube ich in der folge
jeder so ein bisschen eine rüstung
zustande und dann geht es mir schon mal
ein seelisch besser
naja du ich habe mir geht's auch viel
besser wenn ich so eine rüstung einfach
um hab ja weil dann bei dann ist es halt
so gar keine rüstung an dort angegriffen
dann ruhig und zombies ich habe mir
jetzt glätte ich höre einem top liga des
bonner hätten einfach so viel energie
energie
ich habe gold ich habe gold gefunden das
bringt uns wollen absoluten scheißdreck
okay doch kann man nicht mit ich habe ja
- ich hab' diamant raubbau ihn erst ab
wenn irgendwo anders auf dem server ist
damit sie sehen ob jemand alter ich habe
viel diamanten ist gleich für zwei
diamant schwerer als die sofort hoch ich
geh sofort wo ich hab' ich habe
insgesamt vier darmstadt schön wir haben
meine lieben freunde zurückfinden moment
vor ist das schön finde jetzt auch noch
vier und dann haben wir jedoch noch ein
helm oder so wäre wäre die zähne cefic
dabei ist schön
sixx die abbauen hier ja geil geil geil
ich also das mit den diamanten und nicht
jetzt freut mich riesig hätte nie
gedacht dass wir so weit kommen ja und
irgendwann mal überhaupt dieses wort
jemand in den mund nehmen dürfen sich
richtig gut ist ja immer noch bestens
super und ihr wisst ja ich bin ich so
von anfang an gesagt dass unsere
konstellation so werden auch unterhalten
und
in erst folge sterben aber nicht so also
das was man irgendwas sagen genau was
folgend ist ja ich bin ja jemand muss
man ja gar nicht oben ich dachte ich da
macht jemand in den ofen absoluter profi
und hat ihm sagen ich habe ja pvp ein
bisschen geübt mit dem schwert bitte da
bin ich da bin ich heute bin ich da für
dich nicht da fühle ich mich super super
gut so einfach wie schön das ist dieses
diamant schwert im inventar zu sehen
gibt mir auch vor allem wolle nicht dass
wir uns jetzt in eisenstadt gemacht
haben ja moment so darfst du jetzt nehme
ich an dich
wieso kann man eigentlich ich weiß es
nicht normalerweise kommt dann kommt
management aber das ist das richtig
richtig gut und jetzt da drin ist auch
reisen macht ihr da schon mal irgendwie
irgendein helm und ich gehe mal war
darunter ok gut ich bin happy wie also
mal ganz ehrlich das ist ja das ja das
ist unglaublich ich mache uns erst mal
eine kiste dabei fast genau weiß was
nach in den kommentaren steht ja dass es
steht also was drin wie von wegen soja
krankhafter und spd haben inzwischen die
polizei mit die feuern sich freuen sich
über zwei diamanten so was steht da drin
ja ich bin mir ziemlich sicher wir was
wir drinnen stehen so leute da sie
nichts können
am rumpf kurzen ja öfters mal während du
aufnimmst ich immer durch das ist nicht
bei migros nicht seine ehefrau zu
einfach die ganze zeit immer immer
wieder aufnehmen hart klotzen kann ja
doch eine vergangenheit als olympia
forza das war eine disziplin die ist
dann nach unten rauskommen
er hat sich ja wirklich das zeug drauf
also wenn du den privat trifft unterwegs
direktion damit entgegen das aber
häufig den eine andere trophäe hier
schon prophetisch
das ist immer so kleine kleine herrschen
wollte schon sagen ich muss jetzt erst
mal noch ein bisschen holz schön dass
wir können jetzt rausgehen es regel
nicht weiter gefallen
für die total leben conne romy was
sollte ich denn jetzt machen auch wenn
du wirklich kinos verstehe mich gerade
bisschen als wenn du wirklich
reingefallen werden ich werde meine
ganze stimmung war wieder im keller
naja ich hab jetzt genau jetzt kommt so
ein chat einfach gestalten du bist
richtig still geworden das hat ja schon
einige male dass sie schon so gedacht oh
mann ich war so froh dass wir jetzt was
sie so richtig was gerissen haben
das wie diamanten haben und er kommt
einfach aber es war nicht authentisch
ich würde nie so schreien dabei wenn es
nicht auch so wäre ja ja ja ich hab mir
ich habe mir neulich hat mir so ein
kleiner scherz erlaubt sein denn ab dann
darf er dafür erlaubt sein
richtig viel reisen gerade ich habe
angst dass leute unsere position
verraten wo wir sind dass er echt
traurig letztes geleit kommt das dass
das leck das denke ich mir weg aber mit
meisten schwer da brauche ich da brauche
ich gar kein tabu ich gar kein dahin gar
keinen ehemann schwer zu das wirklich so
wegzog und dort leute soll jetzt ein
bisschen angst ich hab dich ich geh
jetzt mal lieber einen keine zweikämpfe
ich will das mal lieber noch ein
bisschen ko ist habe ich darum halt
schimmelt stimmen zombie rum der fällt
bestimmt gleich runter wenn er mich
bemerkt aber ich baue mir das eisen ab
zum gierig bin ich jetzt dass ich das
mache was schön dass ich freue mich
richtig für uns für dich mich ich habe
das mal kurz gucken 5 hätte ich noch
nicht weiß oder betten wie man zu retten
was war was meinst du genau mit betten
wetten wie lange überleben
mit batman wir wenn wir allein auf dem
server sind können dann mit den acht
überspringt ja stimmt
scriba um eine schüssel kinospaß auf
nutze fackeln
da ist und da ist die schweiz aber ich
will ihn eigentlich erledigen weil ich
angst hat dass er dann in unsere basis
rein rennt ich lasse keinen weg mal in
ruhe ich bin jetzt mal die 16 eisen sind
schon die 16 reisen zurück in die
ballack-rolle 100 diamant schwert ich
finde das gar nicht mehr dazu sagen wo
philippe starck alter wir sind so viel
los ist stark dass diese diamanten von
hass aber ich geh jetz auch mal wieder
rein gestellt dass sie wieder rein
da gehe ich jetzt nicht durch die
serengeti frei haben eine böse hürde bei
uns nehmen also nicht nur eine höhle
aber sonne bereit sind ja auch überall
spinnen gehst du siehst ja noch sozial
luca du ich gehe ganz oft weder die sind
jetzt ist einfach mal skype weg wie
scheiße das hier ist ich bin einfach
raus und die sind überall skelette das
ist kein halo kwadrat weg wie du klingst
bei mir ein bisschen doof
ja du klingst man ja auch ein bisschen
doof aber das jedoch nicht der
verbindung ein bisschen angst nicht
überall skelette und ich bin hier bei
nacht draußen über die tür auf was für
wir haben keine tür kinos aber wir haben
nicht mal gleich die ganze wand raus
wenn schon
wir haben wir haben eine wir haben so
eine klingt okay jetzt sind 20 eisen aus
werden hier gerade eben ich geb ich guck
mal ich komme gleich liegen also
letztlich gesagt hatte wir sollen
produktiv sein dachte ich so an zwei
eisen creeper creeper in unserem haus
reebok ripper lieber privat ribery hat
auch ich habe doch getöteter vor ob gott
war das knapp sind überall und skelett
ich habe hier ein komma bitte raus und
kickt die multivac ganz kurz raus bitte
einfach nur ich komm ich komme kaum
heraus wo bist du denn hier
wenn du direkt links runter gest hier
suchen wir es auch in endermann und
krieger und sonst was doch einfach
wieder rein machst du denn gern ein
bisschen zu viel action action ich komme
jetzt wieder hochkommen kann mal wieder
hoch reckten ende meiner daten direkt
die tür zu hallo ich mache die tür zur
jagd auf mich durch dankeschön und tut
so
geh ich auch mal wieder nach unten an
ihrer kiste macht das war das war aber
echt der kripo war hier drin und er ist
war direkt am explodieren ich habe mit
dem letzten schlag habe ich ihn quasi
noch down gekriegt und ansonsten wäre
das sehr sehr nicht sogar ja nicht sogar
geworden das schien er dir stehen jetzt
da wo du hast stehst wird dürfen
übrigens auch so das ist übrigens regel
werden eine doppel kiste dürfen wir
projekten
das heißt dass sich andere spieler da
nichts dabei ein schild dran da nichts
dran und die ich mal kurz an stellt man
dann ist ein projekt das heißt alle
ankommt da die richtigen sachen rein
aufwand darf man bluten wie man möchte
das mal so zur erklärung so ich mache
mir jetzt eigentlich noch hier und jetzt
auch nichts umwege auf das eisen zu
warten die ganze zeit finde ich glaube
ich glaube ich gehe noch mal runter du
ich mache mir da machen wir dann am ende
der folge irgendwie noch oder nächsten
folge meine volleinsatz und fertig ich
habe drauf gestiegenen cat protect
baldizón und konkrete summen zu dem
moment zu dem thema zu thema zu dem es
zu dem tee zu dem eltern dass da mal
nicht so was einstein und sondern lasst
lieber sowas dann halt immer so was
wertvolle leitung die aria
selbstverständlich selbstständig das so
gut erkannt dank es musste gar nicht das
schlussbild behalten sollte fußball
guardiolas auch essen reintun ja wo es
ist so es ist so gut kann ich es so bei
mir was die ganze zeit voll recht
einfach so leise gestellt wegen regen
macht das super die leute schon noch
immer lauter ja es ist einfach das was
ich mit meinen drei milliarden
abonnenten des unfalls kann man nicht
verhindern dass ich mir bei dir schauen
gehen denn hier ich habe auch keine
bereich bin doch auch so wenn ich jetzt
will ich gleich noch irgendwie was finde
dann werde ich da noch hoch gehen und
mir die albatrosse fertigmachen in den
letzten sekunden dieser episode
ich habe alter ich habe nochmal mein
gott oh mein gott es sind moment ich
sage ich sag's dir gleich ich habe du
das holen
ich habe neun diamanten gefunden 9
fucking diamanten ich habe neun dass ich
war so unfassbar probanten
aber level das ist so der berner das
reicht für jeden für uns für für
diamanten schuhe
das reicht für jeden für uns für
diamanten schule alter das ist heftig
stark machen
wir können wir können wieso nicht
diamanten schulbesuch nicht weil doch
doch ich meine ich damals gesagt uns
jemand schule machen oder was meinst du
willst ja von mir aus diamanten schuhe
aber ich hätte gedacht dass wir auf dem
schießplatz sparen oder so ja wir können
wir können auch spieler wie du willst
also ich habe jetzt schon chef kann und
so aber ja es ist halt wenn wir wenn wir
jetzt ich hab auch schon eisen schuhe an
wirklich noch an der konstanz ist massa
auch in zwei minuten wieder auf viel
geschafft heftig wenn ich bin ich gerade
hoch und macht mir das mal wieder alle
eisenbahnen geklaut medical center okay
okay das ist gut wenn dann kann ich mir
damals plate machen
also ich glaube mit zwei genommen oder
so oder so fast fully leute das ist doch
dass ich doch der wahnsinn das ist echt
schön soll ich mit schule machen oder
kannst ruhig machen also ich könnte auch
gleich die full hose machen da macht ihm
niemand gibt es halt für meine hohl ist
das okay für die ich bin ja klar das ist
auf jeden fall jedoch du hast das haben
wir alles getan wäre genug da haben auch
zwei übrig ok dann habe ich jetzt leute
eine full life diamant schwert und
diamant hose
das ist das ist das krasse ich hätte nie
gedacht dass wir so weit ist es einfach
mehrere nicht altmann mehrere rhederin
diamanten im spiel
ja ja ja dass er stark und so heftig
dass hier so ja du hast zwar gefunden
aber ich habe einen baum gepflanzt
ich brauche ich bald eine neue jobs die
lava war nicht irgendwo unter mir die
vag haben wir einfach entgegen
ich habe doch schon posten des
schweizers geht aus wir könnten ja auch
ne ja wir können uns ja auch einfach mal
einen eimer machen und dann vielleicht
einfach mal auch lava mitnehmen das ja
so ein paar andere haben dass er schon
geschrieben so ja wir haben schon aber
eine gute idee ist die idee aber aber
folgendes conny eigentlich ganz ehrlich
ich habe fast eine vorrüstung ich hab
ein diamant werde ich traue mir das auch
zu wirtsleute weg zu klatschen
entgegensehen ja das würde ich auf jeden
fall ich wird trotzdem erst mal ich
würde nicht sagen dass wir so das team
sind das direkt auf angeblich aber wir
sind gerüstet und das ist eine warnung
an alle ja auch an mich auch an tormann
dichter seine mutter los und ich glaube
jetzt sollten wir die polizei sah
nämlich wird sagen fazit geil was egal
genau und damit gehe ich auch meine der
gravis business server und wir
verabschieden uns zwar erst mal wieder
die bewerbung nicht weil die episode all
das ist auf jeden fall sehr wichtig und
ich möchte dass ihr alle daumen hoch
gehen weil wir diamanten gefunden haben
meine damen und herren das ist krass wir
sind heftig gut drauf heftig heftig gut
drauf und dann sehen wir uns morgen
wieder um 15 uhr gehts weiter
und ihr seid heute oder 15.30 kommt
drauf an kommt immer darauf an wie sie
die schießbahn so um den dreh muss
einfach gucken bisschen